Speaker 1: Let's go to Matt, the social
studies guy. Welcome, Matt, what's going on?
Speaker 4: David So I wanted to ask,
are you familiar with Jamie?
Speaker 5: Raskin had mentioned this a few weeks
back. Now he had mentioned that there's going
to be public hearings of information uncovered
starting next month. I believe it is, yeah.
Speaker 1: January 9th, the January 6th
committee. I'm sorry. June 9th, the
January 6th committee hearings start.
Speaker 4: Okay. And I also want to know.
Speaker 5: I believe his quote he used was,
you know, the the things that are going to
come to light. You know, I'm paraphrasing, but.
Speaker 4: They're going to blow
the roof off the house. Yep. And
now my my question is, I think it's a great idea.
Speaker 5: And I would think you would agree. You
know, we all kind of want to know what has
been uncovered. We want to know, you know,
the nuts and bolts of what happened. Yeah. And
I know there's a good portion of us, probably
all the left. I don't want to overstate
that. Also want to know what's going on.
Speaker 4: I also know.
Speaker 5: That there's a a
contingent on the right who right out of the
gate. They're just going to say, you know,
it's a partizan witch hunt. It's garbage,
it's fake news. You know, what have you.
They're not going to listen, whatever is said.
Speaker 4: So my my question is, you know,
do you do you think there's a portion.
Speaker 5: Of people on the fence who
are going to be swayed by this? You know,
how how effective do you think it's going
to be in actually kind of getting people
to see, you know, what really went on here?
Speaker 1: I think that the effect
of the January 6th hearings,
if they are what Jamie Raskin says they're going
to be, is going to be less about changing minds,
but more about activating people. Because,
remember, we have very low voter turnout in this
country, especially in midterms. So my optimistic
hope would be and there's no guarantee that this
happens if people who don't normally vote here
in those hearings about the terrible things that
were done in trying to steal the election in the
lead up to the Trump riots, that they will say,
you know what, I don't normally vote, but this
time I'm going to. So in my mind, it's more about
activating people than it is about changing minds.
Speaker 5: I see. Very good. Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you for the call,
Matt. The social studies guy. That's going to do
it for calls today. We will take a quick break
and be back with much more right after this